to play Kevin von Eric in the iron claw
Zack Efron relied on unprocessed
nutrient-rich Foods when talking with
Men's Health the actor laid out his
improved regimen in full saying first
meal of the day usually starts with bone
broth I really love bone broth it's
satisfying and it's good for your
stomach his next meal typically
consisted of some sort of veggies with a
really clean source of protein whether
it's chicken beef venison elk anything
he told Men's Health I usually have my
highest carbohydrate meal sort of in the
evening that's usually another really
good source of meat and healthy
carbohydrate like sweet potatoes or
quinoa